[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week beast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Morgenstern's finest ice cream on
Manhattan's Lower East Side where I'm
joined by legendary MC Raekwon the chef
you know him as a founding member of the
wu-tang clan and 22 years ago he bless
us with the hit single ice cream today
we're doing what guys do eating ice
cream talking hip-hop and brace
yourselves for this one we're going to
be trying a first taste of the Wu
inspired Sunday NIC Morgenstern is here
he's busting open the freezer pulling
out all the stops ray ready to get it
going let's go let's go ray when you're
a kid and the ice cream truck we're
coming down the block
do you remember your go-to man he was
big on bomb pops they look like the atom
bomb which seems to red white and blue
one strawberry shortcake you clear balls
and climbed it classy and classic well
this experience is going to be a little
bit different from that experience Nick
really pushes the envelope kind of gives
a chef's touch to the ice cream it's
going to be a blind taste test situation
we're going to be trying some sample
figure out what we're like in figure out
what we're not liking
[Music]
I'm going to start at the top and make
sure the palate isn't blown out right
off the bat mmm and I can already tell
you know I see things like you know the
sweet potato mellow I'm the caramel
burnt honey vanilla so this one will try
clearly just a little back cut the
vanilla you're in the right category it
tastes like a grandmother's window I
mean I know though but if your
grandmother was putting bourbon in your
vanilla oh that's what it is I got
bourbon until version vanilla
that's actually the old granddad version
in the Pamela young do add we're going
to move another direction
[Music]
Colby Ernest just coffee tastes like a
nice Vietnamese coffee not the
Vietnamese coffee no condensed milk in
that that the lemon sheet so it's
Russell my favorite that's my favorite
flavor on the menu right now so all
right those things I got vegetables in
it
this is a weird one yeah is your mother
with me right it doesn't even taste like
ice cream much appeal that it oh it's
like what boom very savory but it's a
fruit
[Music]
longer than a no frog legs ice cream on
my said the whole dude heads to be pen
so intent
what do you feeding me over here the
king of fruits my friends the durian
durian so who knows okay so durian is
the fruit that is all over Southeast
Asia you see them in Chinatown it looks
like a football hanging in like a mesh
net flesh is very creamy like a banana
it stinks
it smells very bad clean like a 50 and
up side by I should stop putting 50 plus
yeah that's the senior citizen joint
right damn you guys sit tight with these
I'm gonna go make these Sunday alright
ray can't have you here and not talk
about food references in your lyrics
because yours are off the charts you
make around just like making a recipe
you know you want to try saying things
that you don't normally hear people say
or do and that's what we do a lot of
people didn't know we're we're talking
about the we knew we've talked about so
it just don't go it just something that
was authentic and you know I wanna being
famous people started to pay attention
to the wrong but let me hit you with
some of my favorites right and you can
decode them for me threat because this
is from all about you because everything
you want I'm near with all muscle
because when I'm in the streets we eat
more ruffles
you know the chick we call money chicks
you know like one thing about me I'm
always presenting slang it's on my mom's
and all that and the reference came from
the chicks came on the ruffles which is
one of my favorite potato chips you know
the rigid rigid punk ass iconic that's
where that's where I got that that line
from I think I have a baggage chips that
day one more for you product boots on
Olive Goose calamari calamari soup and
noodles that fell out y'all
nutritionally other children oh that Ron
my day was you know you know whoever
says now to eat alphabet suits right and
you see the letters and all that
so that's what made me come up with that
rhyme is like you know you sit down you
enjoying your soup and then you look
inside and next thing you know it says
y'all [ __ ] is the truth that
was real authentic right there you
you're not going to hear too many
rappers come with it come with a
metaphorical you know Ron like that all
right ray I could sit here and talk to
you about food there's all day but it
looks like it's the moment a moment of
truth exactly only not waiting for how
did you make this w so detail like that
I was I believe I said it was up late
last night this is the chocolate deluxe
got chocolate ice cream flourless
chocolate cake chocolate whipped cream
we've got some chocolate crust and then
we've got the moon obviously on top to
garnish which is real serious rich
chocolate right here guys this is the
ice cream sundae ice cream sundae has
obviously all the flavors mentioned in
the song so we've got butter pecan we've
got french vanilla the chocolate ice
cream whipped cream obviously we added
two strawberry bonbons and the cherries
because of the method man add live at
the end of the song so all right so
here's my move I'm going right through
the strawberry bon bon
catching some chocolate she's gonna get
a brain freeze I can fish out happily of
a brain freeze do a cannonball into that
brain for you let them try the bonbon
though yeah you know what this is
missing tell me a little splash of
caramel on this one yeah let's do it
loads whizzing let's call it a drizzle
[Music]
there you go pop I just touched a dead a
little splash that splash of caramel was
doing it well this is actually how'd you
make the roux fine we just take this
thing and we put the chocolate in a
little piping bag and you swirl it
really tight and when we add the cake
crumbs to it it makes it more
three-dimensional I look how sharp with
his own you know that that's not the
reactor yeah I mean you know it look it
looks perfect you know I was up cutting
that thing with the razor blade late
last night that's important go tomato
you know a lot of times we would see the
W somewhere and we'd be like what kind
of did you tell me look like off the
goddamn W go that's it it's ice cream
this is it you got my approval
it's a second cool this an important day
in ice cream history that's right
exactly
Morgenstern's is official y'all you come
get this chocolate the longship it's
another level I love it I gotta eat this
whole [ __ ]
[Music]